dave gettleman was uh uh vocal yesterday
via a statement hasn't met with the
media yet but he issued a statement in
connection with the trade of otto
beckham jr and the gm of the giants said
you can win while you build a roster we
do have a plan and this is a part of it
now if they have a plan now it clearly
wasn't the plan they had last year chris
because i don't think the plan consisted
of don't trade odell beckham jr pay him
21.45 million for 12 games and then
trade him after that i don't think that
was the plan so i'm not sure what their
plan was a year ago
and i think that if they have a plan now
it's different than whatever the plan
was last year at this time yeah i
definitely think so no last year at this
time it was all about you know eli
manning and odell beckham jr and we're
gonna put a better supporting cast
around eli and make it work well that
changed some point during the season
where i honestly think they realized
odell beckham jr is exposing eli manning
and putting more pressure on eli manning
and i think that's part of the reason
he's probably out of town from from that
aspect so i think that's that's
interesting i mean the big thing here is
i do believe the giants have a plan
they're a smart organization dave
gettleman this is not his first rodeo
john mara the tisch family all of them i
mean these are smart people who have run
a pretty good organization for a long
long time here but i guess the big
question though is mike is is the plan
draft a quarterback and continue to
build a team and yeah they're not
quitting on the year or are they gonna
just
go all in and go no eli's the
quarterback and we're not gonna draft a
quarterback and we're gonna draft more
players to support him once again which
i think is crazy uh i just wonder which
way they are going to go in that
conversation
i i think they're going to go with a
hybrid approach now that they have two
first draft picks they're gonna use one
on a guy who comes in and helps now
right and another one on a quarterback
and and eli can't be as upset about that
although he could say look you trade
away odell beckham jr we already had a
first round draft pick get me two impact
players who can come in and help right
away and help us get to where we need to
be right yeah and regardless of how this
plays out we were talking about this
yesterday chris if it goes well
and they exceed all expectations they
have a big year do you let the allie
manning walk away or do you try to keep
him what do you do and if it goes poorly
when do you pull the plug and just tank
and hope that you can end up in position
with one of the top three picks in the
draft to get a great quarterback next
year if you like one of the quarterbacks
and i'm going to go back to something
tony dungy said last year yeah regarding
what the giants should do he said
evaluate the quarterbacks in this draft
class and if you think one is going to
be your franchise guy you take him
regardless of eli manning kind of a
twist on the same story he told you last
week about the steelers having terry
bradshaw and not drafting dan marino
right forget about who you have if you
love the guy that's there take him and
the same thing applies this year if at
number six or at number 17 they love the
guy that's there then you take him and
you make him the guy who fits your kc
model but you're not gonna know until
you're on the clock and that guy either
is there or isn't there that you love as
your future quarterback no you're right
and i mean that's why they you know hey
they got the number six pick the number
17 pick so they got the leverage or the
picks there to move up if they have to
if they feel like oh gosh we got to get
up to number two or number three
whatever that may be uh that's a
possibility doesn't that make it even
more likely that they're not trying to
win now if you invest both of your first
round picks into your future quarterback
i was gonna sit this year i mean yeah
aren't you telling the world that's what
exactly what you're doing i mean
yes it does seem that way but i'll throw
out the kansas city chiefs i mean they
they had alex smith and they did that
and they went to the playoffs that year
with patrick mahomes on the bench right
so it's not the first time the ravens
certainly didn't like close up shop this
year they went in the season going we're
going to the playoffs joe flacco got
hurt and all that lamar jackson got a
chance to play and played well and did
that but they were also rebuilding while
trying to win so i don't think it's
totally crazy uh but yeah i think that's
the million-dollar question and yeah i
mean hey again i think as a giants fan
and uh everything i look at i do i think
the giants are letting eli manning kind
of have too much power in this whole
conversation all together uh but at the
same time you know hey they've they've
made their bed they're going forward
with it and i think they're going to
play kind of a different style of
football without odell beckham jr there
they're going to run the ball they still
got sterling shepard and evan ingram and
that type of talent around them uh and i
think pat sherman can make all that work
too
you know we talk all the time about
moves that are made for business reasons
and le'veon bell joining the jets i
think part of that money is being spent
not necessarily for football but because
having le'veon bell on the team
is a good sales approach to get people
to choose to come to the games to choose
to watch the games to buy the jerseys to
be excited i feel like the giants kind
of have that idea turned on its head
with eli manning they went through it a
couple years ago when ben mcadoo did
that clumsy awkward benching of eli
manning and the fan base lost their
minds i feel like they're keeping eli
manning as long as they are because
they're afraid of how their fans are
going to react that it's like disowning
a member of your family and the fans why
even though they want to reserve the
right to complain about eli's
performance they want eli there as long
as he wants to be there he secured a
lifetime pass from that fan base by
winning two super bowls tom coughlin
didn't but eli manning did and the
organization has so much more patience
with eli manning because i guarantee you
chris if you take away those two super
bowls he's already gone oh no and if you
do it if you're doing it if you take
manning off the back of the jersey and
you put a mask on his face and you don't
know who he is and you watch his film
he's gone yeah this is because he won
two super bowls it's because his name is
eli manning this is because the fans
love him that is what's buying him extra
chances and it's dragging down the team
it's similar to what's going on in
pittsburgh where the fans won't get mad
at the team for mismanaging the roster
in in new york the fans are going to get
mad at the team if they properly manage
the ross yeah no you're exactly right
and that's what drives me crazy it
really does as a guy that's yeah i'm a
giants fan i really am and i know i have
relationships around the nfl and there's
some games where i go oh man i you know
hey it's kyle shanahan and i really like
him and he's a good friend i'm gonna
root for the 49ers over the giants yeah
that's what happens when you've been in
the business for a while but when it
comes down to it the giants are the team
that have my heart and the team i root
for and people i know when they hear me
say these things about eli manning hey
this is not personal uh it's not and i
know i'm the son of phil sims and it
looks like i'm being a hater no eli
manning has been great i really like eli
manning i'm just giving you the football
aspect of it and yes right now it looks
like they're placating or playing to eli
manning and letting the team hold
letting him hold the team hostage
basically to a degree and it's a time
where yeah i think it's time to move on
and they might be sacrificing years of
of quality teams here down the stretch
just
for this effort to give the swan song so
he could walk off into the sunset and
everyone could go oh look eli ended on a
good note and it was all great and you
know hunky dory so yeah from that that
standpoint it just it bothers me as a
fan of the giants and a guy who
evaluates football
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports